hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make math a
lot less stressful so let's get right
into this lesson for today we're going
to talk about mathematical induction so
when students first learn about
mathematical induction a lot of times
they're just like what is all this you
know what we were doing precalculus a
minute ago and now all of a sudden
what's all this so let me see if I can
explain to you how this works and we'll
do a couple of examples and hopefully
this will be a lot clearer for you so
when you do the process of proving
something by mathematical induction
there's four steps that we follow and
let me see if I can just go through the
steps real quick with you the first step
is you want to show that it's true for
the first term so N equals 1 because if
the formula doesn't work for the first
term then you know it's it's just not
true so there's no sense in proceeding
from there ok so then you go to the step
number 2 and you make this assumption
you say let's assume that this pattern
ok this this theorem this formula is
true for N equals K now n is the number
of terms and K represents like you know
like a set number of terms like five
terms ten terms like like a fixed number
of terms and this is called the
mathematical induction assumption just I
abbreviated it here am i a mathematical
induction assumption so you make an
assumption that it's true you know and
you can show that it's true for two
terms three terms four terms but when we
get to step number three what we're
trying to do is we're trying to prove or
show that it's true for N equals K plus
1 so that means like one term beyond
that fixed number of terms K okay
because if it works for one term beyond
that it'll work for one term beyond that
and beyond that ad infinitum right
forever so then the last step once
you've proven this step number three
this is the bulk of the proof this is
usually the the biggest part of the
proof the last step is just to restate
therefore that's what these three dots
represent therefore by the process of
mathematical induction and restate what
it was that you were trying to prove
originally okay
in the proof so let's go ahead and get
into this example here what we're trying
to prove is that 3 plus 6 plus 9 plus 12
plus dot dot dot dot plus 3 n okay
equals and this is a formula for the sum
of all these terms okay so let's see if
we can prove this so first step stop
number one I'll label the steps we're
going to say show true okay show two
four and equals one so I'm gonna put one
in right here this is our formula for
finding any term so I'm just gonna say
three times one and then this represents
the sum of all the N terms in this case
just the sum of the first one term okay
so 3 times 1 1 plus 1 all divided by 2
so what we get here is we get 3 equals
and this is 3 times 2 divided by 2 and
you can see the twos cancel so 3 equals
3 I'm just going to put a little check
mark okay so you're with me so far
this is the probably the easiest step
right just to show that it works for the
first term but your teacher could trick
you and just give you a formula it just
doesn't work and you'd say well you know
it doesn't work for the first term so
it's not true right okay let's go to
step number two so step number two we're
just gonna and you want to write these
little statements in here this is
important for the proof you don't want
to just do it you want to say okay show
true for N equals 1 assume true okay for
N equals K and what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to rewrite this formula but
instead of using n which is more like a
generic way of saying n number of terms
any number of terms we're gonna say more
for like a a set number or a fixed
number of terms we're going to go up to
the caithe term okay whatever that
represents could be 10 terms 20 terms
but like a fixed number okay so let's go
ahead and replace n with K because we're
just going up to 2 K number of terms so
that's our mathematical induction
assumption we could write mi a here okay
okay now we're on to step three so step
three we're gonna write show true or
prove true okay
for N equals K plus one so we're going
to the K plus 1 term the one term beyond
K terms so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to rewrite this formula 3 plus 6
plus 9 plus 12 plus dot dot plus 3k
that's up to the K term ok whatever K is
10 but now we're gonna go one additional
term K plus 1 now if we add all these
terms up to the K plus 1 term the sum
should be 3 times k plus 1 because
that's how many terms we have k plus 1
plus 1 all over 2 so you can see I just
replaced n with k plus 1 because that's
how many terms we're adding up now this
is the bulk of the proof and let me just
give you some pointers here a lot of
times students they forget to write this
K term and then to write the K plus 1
term they'll just go right up to k plus
1 skipping over this term so you want to
write all this and I'll show you why the
reason is is because what we're gonna do
now is we're gonna say all right the sum
of the first K terms right here what
does that equal well we can see here
from the previous step it equals 3 K
times K plus 1 divided by 2 so what
we're gonna do is we're going to replace
that okay right there this sum of these
first K terms equals this so we're gonna
write that right here 3 K times k plus 1
divided by 2 okay
Plus this term here that's our K plus 1
term 3 times K plus 1 equals and we're
trying to show that it equals this right
here ok so here with me so far so this
is just algebra and I just want to state
something here for you that you don't
want to necessarily foil and multiply
all this out what you can do sometimes
is you can take what you have right here
and work with that you can say well hmm
I know that I'm trying to show that it
equals this I can see I already have a K
plus 1 in both of these groups maybe I
can factor that out so I don't have to
multiply this out and then try to like
you know factor it from there but what
I'm going to do here is I'm going to
multiply the top
the bottom times - okay this way we get
a common denominator okay so now if I
can just rewrite this we've got three K
times k plus 1 plus 6 okay cuz 2 times 3
times k plus 1 all divided by 2 we got a
common denominator now when you look at
this group in this group see how you
have like 3 in common you can factor out
an a k plus 1 let's factor that out so
what we have here is we have 3 times k
plus 1 times we're left with K from this
group plus 2 from this group all divided
by 2 now you can see we're almost there
all I'm going to do now is I'm just
gonna rewrite
k plus 2 2 is the same as 1 plus 1 so
I'm just going to break this down so it
looks a little bit more like the right
side so we've got k plus 1 times k plus
1 plus 1 all divided by 2 okay so now
we've proved it you can see that these
are the same so the last step step
number four is to restate what it is
that you were trying to prove so I'm
just gonna put it right here step number
four therefore okay there's a lot of
different symbols that you can use but
this is a common one therefore you can
say by the process okay by the process
of mathematical induction and then what
I'm going to do is I'm going to restate
what it is that we were trying to prove
3 plus 6 plus 9 plus 12 plus dot dot
plus 3 and equals and the formula for
the sum is 3 n times n plus 1 all
divided by 2 and that's it we proved it
so let's take a look at another example
I'm gonna erase the board and I'll be
back and right half a second okay okay
in this next example what we're going to
do is we're going to prove this other
theorem here which is 1 plus 2 plus 2
squared plus 2 cubed plus 2 to the
fourth plus dot dot all the way to 2 to
the N minus 1 power if you were to add
up all these terms we're going to show
that the sum equals 2 to the nth power
- one so notice this n minus one is an
exponent this minus one is just over
here to the side so we're gonna go
through the same four steps step number
one we're gonna show that it's true for
N equals one so let's do that here and I
would write again these steps out I
would say step number one show true for
okay for N equals one so I'm just going
to put one in for n here and I've got
two to the one minus one equals and this
is the sum of the first one terms which
is two to the first minus one one minus
one is of course 0 2 to the first is to
anything the 0 power is 1 and 2 minus 1
is 1 okay so step number one done okay
so now step number two we're going to
assume true for N equals K this is our
mathematical induction assumption and we
want to start off by writing that we're
doing that so I'm just going to
abbreviate mathematical induction
assumption one plus two plus two squared
plus two cubed plus dot dot dot plus two
to the K minus 1 plus 2 to the K well
let's just go right to there okay out
there for a second so we're all we're
doing is replacing mm-hmm and with case
we're just showing that it works for the
first k terms okay so all we did was
replace n with K and we're just saying
that the sum of the first K terms this
is true so that's our assumption so
that's done now step number three here's
where the bulk of our proof we're going
to prove true or show true okay for N
equals k plus 1 okay so now we're going
to go beyond the K term one additional
term if it works for that it's going to
work for one beyond that one beyond that
forever and ever and then we've proved
it so by the process of mathematical
induction so let's do that we've got 1
plus 2 plus 2 squared plus 2 cubed plus
dot dot plus 2 to the K minus 1 that's
the K term plus we're going to go one
more term beyond that
2 to the K plus 1 minus 1 equals 2 to
the K plus 1 minus 1 okay so just to
restate this is the first K terms this
is the K plus 1 term and I put k plus 1
in for n because n is whatever term
you're on so the K plus 1 term and then
this over here on the right side is the
formula for the sum of not just n terms
not just K terms but k plus 1 terms ok
so here with me so far okay this is the
bulk of the proof and I just want to
point out the key points here and that's
that a lot of students they forget this
part right here ok I used to forget this
part myself I'd say okay the sum of the
first K terms here what is that equal we
showed here that it equals 2 to the K
minus 1 so let's do that substitution 2
to the K minus 1 plus this is the K plus
1 term so that's 2 to the k plus 1 minus
1 equals we're trying to show that it
equals this right here ok so 2 to the k
plus 1 minus 1 ok so you're with me so
far
now 1 minus 1 of course equals 0 right
so this is just 2 to the K this is 2 to
the K this is minus 1 and we're trying
to show it equals this but because we
have two of these you could really write
this as 2 times 2 to the K minus 1 ok
we're with me so far so we have one of
these plus one of these we have 2 2 to
the K + 2 is really like 2 to the first
when you multiply and you have the same
base you add two exponents so this is
going to be 2 to the k plus 1 in case
I'm adding minus 1 equals and that's
what we were trying to show that it made
it equalled so we proved it ok so that
was good so then the last step we just
want to restate ok therefore by the
process of mathematical induction what
we set out to prove is in fact true and
so you just kind of you know bring
everything full circle by stating that
so therefore by the process ok of
mathematical induction
one plus two plus two squared plus two
cubed plus dot dot dot plus two to the K
minus up I'm using K we want to use n
this is very important you want to use n
because ends like a generic a for any
number of terms we were using K as just
a fixed number of terms a set number of
terms we definitely wanna use n okay
that's just a general number of terms
equals two to the N minus one so there
you go process of mathematical induction
I hope you learn something go ahead and
subscribe to the channel I've got more
videos like these and I've got more
coming I look forward to seeing you in
future videos I'll talk to you soon